nearly three months since Lisa Marie
Presley's death mom Priscilla is getting
emotional over her rumored war with
granddaughter Riley Keough
that's Elvis's ex mobbed by fans in
London on night three of her and evening
to remember with Priscilla Presley q a
tour today we talked to one fan who got
a meet and greet backstage with
Priscilla on night two she was very
emotional and she did also tear up a lot
when she
um mentioned Riley remember both
Priscilla and Riley are locked in a
battle for control of Lisa Marie's
multi-million dollar estate we were
initially told it left Riley deeply
upset feeling like Priscilla is pushing
the family apart and that they aren't
communicating Jackie reveals what the 77
year old is saying now about some
tabloid headline that isn't the case
Riley and I are getting on well she said
you know I went to dinner with her
before I came away she said everything's
good she said there's a journey she's
going around saying that you know we're
falling out but that's not the case at
all you know she had dinner with her and
it's all good I don't even know where to
begin you got the Rockstar DNA and it
came flying out of you sis no for real
I'm not even I can do this
[Applause]
as for Riley's role in Daisy Jones and
the six grandma was gushing like she did
with E.T back in 2017. I am so proud of
her she's she's a great little actress
she came across as being very proud she
said I am really proud of her we are
really proud of what she's achieved
despite the praise both women still have
a court date set for May 16th
foreign
[Music]